hi my name is oli
i'm a student in tel aviv university and
today i'm going to talk about comparison
graphs
a unified method for uniformity testing
so what is property testing basically we
have some large job objective we wish to
test and this object can be a
graph or a distribution maybe a function
we want to test for some properties so
we're not able to see the entire prod
object because it is so large but we can
maybe ask if a graph
is bipartite whether a function is
monotone or very far from that and the
complexity measure is the bits of
information that we're allowed to see so
the samples that we get from
this very large object and once we get
our samples and this is
quite this is a randomized process we're
trying to
answer whether we have a property of
we're far from that
with a high constant probability
so in this talk we're going to focus on
distribution testing and specifically
the problem of uniformity testing
and in the problem of infinity testing
we were exposed to samples from a
distribution
that is over a domain of size n
and we need to distinguish the two cases
well the yes instance would be the
specific
uniform distribution over the entire
domain overall an
element and to no instances
would be every distribution that is
epsilon far from uniform
and by epsilon phi i mean in l1 distance
or otherwise statistical distance
total variation distances these are all
the same
and up to a constant factor this
problem in the standard model was sold
long long time ago so let me give you
some broader background about that
so uniformity testing was first
introduced in fox 2000
in a paper by two fort no ruben felt
smith and white
but it was also implicitly used in a
collagen one
in 2000 and the method used is the
collision-based tester and their
analysis showed the square root of n
over epsilon to the fourth
is actually enough samples to perform
informative testing
but even for the easiest case where
epsilon is large
or epsilon is a constant the birthday
paradox shows that
you cannot perform uniformity testing
and unless you have at least square root
of
n order of code of n samples
so the dependency of n is quite clear
right in the beginning but the
dependency
on epsilon the proximity parameter kind
of
made a mystery and it stayed a mystery
for roughly 10 years until the paper by
peninsula in 2008 showed a lower bound
of square root of n over epsilon squared
and a matching upper bound but not for
every
value of epsilon rather only for large
enough values of epsilon
and the paper six years later by chen
the nicolas valentin valiant
also used a different method the
different tester to show
that this is indeed the right
sample complexity for the entire range
of possible values for epsilon
another paper that i would like to
mention is
a paper by the aqua nicolas coolikis
peoples and price
from 2016 that actually shows that the
original test of the collision-based
tester
is optimal so using square root of n
over epsilon squared samples and
performing the collision based tester
would work
okay so what is exactly the
collision-based tester well it relies
upon the
notion of collision probability and
collision probability of the
distribution is basically the chance of
two independent samples from set
distribution
to have the same value or alternatively
this is the
l2 norm squared of the distribution
and two simple fact about this
this notion of collision probability is
this well
if we consider all the distributions
over a domain of size n
since we want to minimize the
probability of seeing collisions
is a uniform distribution and this is
quite non-trivial but
a tiny bit less trivial fact
is that this is quite robust so any
distribution that is
epsilon far from being uniform where
again we're epsilon firing l1 distance
it has this condensed mass over
few elements it would cause more
collisions it has a noticeably larger
collision probability
that's being said at least one plus
epsilon squared over n
which is a noticeable gap from the one
the collision probability of the uniform
distribution
so our strategy would be to estimate
this probability the collision
probability of the distribution
that we get samples from
and once we do that well we can
um if we have a good approximation and
a good estimation of the collision
probability we can compare it to some
threshold and if it's
small enough then we'll say it's uniform
and if it's large enough then we'll
probably got samples from a non-uniform
distribution
so a very naive estimation would go
just by definition i would say okay what
what happens if i draw two samples and
compare them
well then i can observe the indicator of
whether they had the same value or not
and this indicator is either 0
1 which is kind of useless but what's
good about this indicator is that
in expectation this is going to be
exactly
the collision probability so what we
need to do is to make
more compare comparisons and average
over many such indicators
and indeed this is what
colors and drawing were doing and
in order to maximize the amount of
comparisons with
minimal samples you would want to
compare basically
every possible term let me just
uh point out that we do create some
dependencies which might interfere in
the future
for example we can see that s1 is
compared both with s3 and s2 so the
indicator of this comparison and the
indicator of the other comparison
are not independent so some dependencies
are created
and this is actually the reason that the
optimal analysis took so long to
achieve so the tester is this
draw q samples compare all possible
pairs and normalize by the number of
pairs so
count the collision normalized by the
number of comparisons that you've made
and this is a good estimation for the
good religion
probability as long as q is large enough
okay so let me jump back to some
to the present some recent
line of work about distribution testing
and this landform considered
distribution testing under constraints
or in various models and not necessarily
the
standard classic models that were used
and let me just quickly go over some
models that are considered
lately so one model would be a
multi-party interactive model
where we have many players and each one
of them
gets either a single sample or maybe
several samples
from the distribution and they can
interact with one another
and they somehow collectively need to
output a decision
about whether the underlying
distribution has some property or not
and another model would be simultaneous
model where the players cannot interact
but each of them
has its own samples and its own
decision or idea of the answer because
only send a short message or a signal
to some referee and the referee collects
all the signals from all the players
and it needs to output again whether the
underlying distribution has a property
or is very far from having it
and another model being considered is a
stream model and we're going to get into
that one
uh later on but basically it's a samples
now arrive as a stream
and we cannot store all the samples all
together but we need to store only some
of them and while processing
the entire stream by the end of it we
want to
decide whether we have the property or
not
and i kept on saying deciding whether we
have the property but
usually i think like 80
of these papers concerned with
uniformity testing
and this is not only because this is the
most fundamental
um problem in distribution testing
but also there's a good reason for that
this is also a very useful
problem so here's some reasoning for
that
and some evidence so say we get samples
from an unknown distribution well the
optimal goal would be to
learn the distribution but even if i
want to learn the distribution
or if i want to output a distribution
that is somewhat close
to the real distribution this would take
order of the domain size linear
number of samples in the domain sizes
which is quite a lot because we know
that for uniformity testing we only
need the square root of the domain
inside
and here's a better idea well maybe i'll
start by having some distribution in
mind not necessarily the uniform
distribution but some distribution
and now i only wish to test whether the
samples come from
these exact distributions that i had in
mind or something that is very far
off and this task is called
identity testing it's much faster than
actually learning the distribution
therefore it is very useful and the work
by diacon nicolas and ken from 2016
actually shows
that identity testing can be reduced to
uniformity testing
and a modified reduction made by gold
life later that year
is actually so black box that you can
use it in
any known model where distribution
testing is being considered
so basically for each one of these
models
not only we solve uniformity testing or
we have some
testers that can test for uniformity
but we also get
identity testers for all of these models
so let me try and give you some
motivation
so our motivation is going to be the
following
maybe not only we can solve um
all these identity testing tasks using
uniformity testing specifically but
maybe we can also
solve uniformity testing and therefore
all identity testing
problems in a generic way that would fit
many different models and of course we
don't presume to
to include all models some of those
might be very peculiar
but maybe a lot of models can be
captured
using the same perspective
and indeed one candidate for that is the
collision-based tester because
ideas of the sort something like
approximate collision probability arise
in
more more than one model in the last
couple of years
and of course the main obstacle is that
if we reduce ourselves to the original
collision based tester well
it tries to compress all the pairs and
this is obviously impossible in any
constraint that you can think of
so we need to adjust it we need to
somehow generalize
the notion of collision based testing
and we do this using the definition of
comparison graph
so what are comparison graphs well this
is a new perspective of
how we view our samples and which cycles
we
choose to compare so
the set of nodes in a comparison graph
actually has a sample on each node
sitting on each node and the set of
edges
is a pairs of nodes because of samples
that we're willing to compare
and different set of comparisons would
create different set of
dependencies you know
and using this we can induce
a generalized notion of a
collision-based tester
where each graph induces a specific
instance of a collision-based tester
and it does in the following way well
the edges
merely indicate where do we want to
look for collisions so for each edge of
g we have the
indicator of whether it has a collision
on the two sides of it or not
and the estimation for the collision
probability what the tester the
algorithm will do is basically
try to approximate using
only the comparisons that are indicated
that are
dictated by the graph g so only
summing collision indicators over the
edges of the graph g and of course
normalizing by the number of edges
and as usual well if we got a low
estimation we would say uniform
high estimation would say this is far
from uniform this is business as usual
okay so let's try and go over some
examples to see the duality between
algorithms and the graph states induced
algorithms so the original version the
original algorithm
basically take a bunch of samples and
compare all possible pairs
and this is of course the click graph
right because we take every
pair of samples and compare them well
let's see
what a different graph would be so let's
say star graph the first
graph that came to mind and this can
this also induces sound tester
and one way to define this tester is
maybe
okay we take the first sample we put it
in the middle and we compare every other
single sample with that one
so i don't know what this would give us
it's probably not a good
estimator for the collision probability
however a different algorithm that we
have in mind
actually proves itself to be quite
useful
this is the following so maybe we have a
large set of samples might be even more
samples that we would need in the
classical model
but it would be much easier to divide
them into small batches and only compare
within those batches so
the comparisons are somewhat in a sense
more local
you know so we take this large amount of
samples or nodes that we have and we
divide them into this disjoint clicks
and within each each you know batch we
have a full click because we compare all
the pairs
within this patch just a small note
while this graph is somewhat comparable
to the first graph where we have
one huge click well if we want to have
the
same amount of comparisons not nodes but
comparisons edges
then of course we need more nodes to
achieve that
when we have what we need to have many
different clicks
but on the other side when we take
small batches when we take many
different clicks
apparently we would create far less
dependencies than we would have
in the original tester so this is
something to keep in mind
and it can be illustrated by taking an
extreme case
well if we divide ourselves to batches
of size 2
this is basically taking graph which is
a perfect matching
well the resulting algorithm is ok draw
a new fresh pair of samples for each
comparisons you make
so now each collision indicator each
comparison that we make is completely
independent from all the other ones
that we use so here we drop the
dependencies to
virtually none oh how can we use this
new perspective this new
definition of comparison graph well let
me take you back to 2016.
this is the analysis of the original
tester and we're not going to
go into any technical details at all but
this is that we now label as a split
graph
and we know that by taking counting
collision normalizing by the number of
comparisons
you know that this is a value that the
expectation should be close to
uh should be exactly its collision
probability but we want you to
be close and for this we need some
concentration measure
and indeed what they show is what one
would show that whenever the number of
samples is at least square root of n
over epsilon squared is called
the number since the variance gets low
enough
but in actuality a closer look
shows that the variance consists of two
different terms
and one of them actually gets smaller
merely because we have enough
indicators we make enough comparisons in
our algorithm
while the second one well the second one
drops because we don't create too many
dependencies
this is quite abstract but actually we
can quantify these dependencies
and we played with that before so a
dependency
would be quantified by two comparisons a
pair of comparisons the cherished sample
so every time we have
this image inside our comparison graph
these two paths
this is a dependency right there
okay so now we can get a structural
result
over the notion of comparison graphs
and it goes as follows whenever a
comparison graph
fulfills two conditions then it is
guaranteed to induce
a good uniformity tester so first let me
just
remind you a good energy uniformity
tester means that with high constant
probability
we can distinguish the case that the
underlying
distribution is uniform from the case
that the underlying distribution is
epsilon far from uniform say in l1
distance
and the two conditions that the graph
needs to hold
is as we said before well one is that it
makes enough comparison so the number of
edges
is large as a function of an epsilon and
two
is that it has a relatively few
dependencies
and as we just said well dependencies
are quantified by
two path so we define cg to be the
number of two paths in the graph g
and this should be this ratio of c
g as to the total number of pairs
of comparisons not pairs of samples but
now it's pairs of comparisons
this ratio should be small enough okay
so the details doesn't really matter
much
but let's just see how this generalizes
the previous result
the previous analysis in 2016 well the
previous analysis was
correct specifically for the graph of
this structure to these
click over q samples but for this
structure
we know that the number of nodes the
number of samples is q
the number of comparisons is exactly our
order of q squared
and the number of dependencies created
is of ordered q to the third
and having these values in mind so we
know that this single condition this one
condition that
the number of samples is more than
square root of n
over epsilon squared you notice it's
called the number again and again
then this an easy calculation that i'm
not going to go over
shows that both condition 1 and
condition 2
actually hold for a click of t
size of size q and this immediately
guarantees us that this is a good
uniformity tester
so good our theorem actually generalizes
the previous analysis
so the last part of our talk i want to
get to the punch line and show you some
application and another short disclaimer
we're here again we're going to
ignore constant and close text
so let's see what is the generic
recipe that we use in order to leverage
the previous results and devise
a tester in a new model
so we have to test the requirement these
are known to all we need
the uniform distribution to be accepted
with high probability and and any
far distribution to be rejected with
high probability this is not going to
change
for different models however with
different models we
might have different complexity measure
probably would be related to its number
of samples but not necessarily
and we also would have the model
constraints and this is the interesting
part
and the main idea is well let's
translate
all of these to graph notation let them
speak in same language
and well the first part we've already
seen
we did have the structural theorem
theorem one that
said okay if we have certain type of
crafts then
we're guaranteed to to
they are guaranteed to induce a working
uniformity
tester this is good but
with those other parts that's a concern
with the model well we have to use some
heuristics obviously for each model
we'd have to use some other heuristics
and hopefully
we're going to get something interesting
but once we've done that
and we got everything in line with graph
constraints and graph measure
then the problem becomes kind of
straightforward not necessarily easy
usually is but
definitely straightforward well we
simply want to optimize some graph
measure
and we can only choose graph that
answers the constraints of the model and
the constraint
of the tester requirement in order to
actually induce uniformity tester
and all we are left is is choosing the
right graph
so this is i think the main core idea of
the paper
let's see um one
way to realize that and we're going to
do that
in the streaming model so we're going to
talk about the string model
in the next couple of minutes um
and in the streaming mode of the problem
of uniformity testing was first
introduced a year and a half ago 2019 by
theoconicolas goligis canon drow
and i think the wishful thinking of
their algorithm
is somewhat following so we have a long
stream of samples but we can only store
m samples at a time the idea is
why not let's store the first m samples
and use some
sort of collision testing to
try and compare these with all the rest
of the samples so upon receiving
another sample and now sample we simply
compare them with
those samples this first batch that we
put in our memory
and for each sample we do that and
we also need to maintain in the memory
some global collision counter but trust
me this is
not very hard it takes very little space
and when we're done with that and
hopefully we've done
we've taken enough samples and we have
done enough
comparisons then we can do some sort of
collision basis so we can
uh estimate the collision probability
and then answer whether we're uniform or
not
this is the idea in principle but
the execution is not quite as easy as
sounds like it should be and
actual tester well it has some
adjustment
it doesn't it does do a bit more than
just counting collisions
and this modification this adjustment
this
added procedures actually affect the
analysis
quite heavily so the analysis is not as
straightforward as you
think and
after doing some fine work they do end
up obtaining
tester but it doesn't work for
every parameter so it does have a
limited range so this
this analysis comes with cost
so it's great analysis and it shows a
very good sample complexity
when it works but it doesn't work for
every parameter every
value of the parameter memory parameter
m
however they do show that in certain
range of m not only that it works and
keeps a good tester but they show a
tight lower one so this is an optimal
tester
this is definitely a way to go
but somewhat some somewhat it still
seems a bit
off and maybe a way to understand it is
through the
um comparison graph perspective
so i have to say that they did call this
a tester
a bipartite collision tester
because obviously we compared the first
batch of samples m with the entire
second batch of samples and prime and
they knew what they were doing
but still just let me put it right on
your face
so this is the comparison graph that
we're trying to uh
to use is the comparison graph that
supposedly induces
the tester we said this tester does a
bit more than
just counting collision but it's
presumed to be
the letter induced by this comparison
graph and their analysis
also gives this the same
conditions that we got on our uh
in our structural theorem that the
number of comparisons
will present specifically for any
bipartite comparison graph
but still the number of comparisons
might must be at least
n over epsilon to the fourth and
since we assume that m prime is the
larger portion of the stream
so the sample complexity is basically n
prime which is n over
m epsilon to the fourth and this is the
this is
probably the optimal sample complexity
for this problem whenever it's possible
to obtain
it notice it well i've written the
the conditions of our structure out
there and here
on the right side note that the first
the first
condition they got the same condition in
their analysis
but for the second condition well we
cannot
hope to fulfill it we cannot
hope to apply our structural theorem
because this type of graph that's a
bipartite complete graph
it just has too many dependencies
especially when when
m is rather small so we have these
edges these vertices samples with very
very
high degree so we said that
dependencies are quantified by the
number of two paths and in a complete
bipartite graph we have
quite we had a lot of them
and we cannot even hope to apply our
theorem
so what exactly went wrong or is there
anything that went wrong
and what i think is the right
perspective
is that this graph actually it meets too
many dependencies
maybe maybe they are unnecessary and
this is also the reason why
why the previous results were a bit
rocky you know they needed to
use heavy analysis and they needed to
adjust the algorithm a little bit and
probably because the dependencies here
very problematic so maybe we can ditch
those
dependencies what maybe we can use
a different graph instead not the right
graph for the streaming model
and this brings us to the question what
is the right graph and how do we choose
a graph for the streaming model
this is a good question and here's a
partial answer
we do obtain a nice lemma about the
streaming model
that states following if a tester
a collision based tester that is induced
by sound comparison graph g
can be computed simulated in the
streaming model with memory
of at most n samples
then it means that the average degree of
g
cannot be too high it cannot be larger
than two times
m so the maximal degree can be high
because we can take the first
sample as we do let's say doing the
other tester
we can take the first sample and compare
it basically to the rest of the stream
and it will have a very high degree but
the average degree cannot be too high
this is indeed this holds true for the
complete bipartite graph
but it holds true for other graphs it
seems maybe
more pleasant they
don't have as many dependencies as the
bipartite graph and
they might be a better candidate for
collision that is testing
in the streaming model so
what was the problem the problem was
that kept those
same samples for a long long time and
they got
they they ended up gaining many many
dependencies because we
compared them to many different circles
and the idea and it encapsulated in this
graph
the idea is okay let's get rid of the
oldest sample every time we process a
new
sample not only we compared it with all
the samples that we have in our memory
but we also replace we take the oldest
sample in the memory
and we replace it with the newest one
this means that
any sample upon being processed is
compared to the last m
minus one samples that have been
processed before it
and it's going to stick in our memory
for another a minus one step so it's
going to be compared to
the next minus one samples so its degree
is going to be
almost two times m and this is
almost optimal with this restriction
that we have by the
by the model constraints and
this is a nice graph and we can analyze
this graph but
there is an even simpler graph that we
can analyze and
probably or probably without losing
a more than a constant factor in our
complexity measure the number of samples
and if we give up a bunch of comparisons
that
maybe we can just divide and conquer
maybe we can
make the following each time we take a
batch of m samples and we compare them
only among themselves
so this is essentially a click and then
we just get rid of them
and take the new batch and again make
comparison only within this patch and
throw them out and so on and so forth
all in the meanwhile of course just as
before we we said that it
cost us very little uh memory
space to um
to keep track on the global collision
counter
so let me just sum up because this is
this is the true graph this is the
correct graph
to choose for this model
and to sum up this would be a little bit
checked just when we squeeze it
into the generic recipe
well the tester requirements uh stands
for theorem one and
we know how they look like but
specifically for the streaming model
well we have this heuristic
and we had this streaming lemma that
said okay if we can only store m samples
at a time
this means that the average degree is at
most two times m
and this is what our graph must fulfill
and the samples in the entire stream
this is a complexity
measure the number of samples that we
see in the entire stream and this is
simply the number of nodes in the graph
and as we said before so this easily
leads us to
a nice uh structure of a graph that
fulfills all these requirements
and the graph is k disjoint clicks of
size
n and
well i'm going to skip this small
calculation in the cloud but
essentially it's very easy to calculate
and see
that the total number of samples in this
model
in this for this comparison graph for
this algorithm
is still n over m times epsilon to the
fourth which means this is the optimal
central complexity the same sample
complexity obtained by say
by apartheid collision tester only now
this can be obtained for any
parameter at as long as we do have
enough memory
to store more than two samples in order
to make
a single comparison and we do need
enough
memory to keep track on the global
collision counter but this is very cheap
okay so this kind of sums it up
so let's just have a quick look at the
simultaneous model and how we can
apply our generic recipe to that model
so the constraint of the model without
going far into the details is that we
have k
players but they cannot interact so each
of them can obtain
samples and they send a short message to
the referee they cannot interact with
one another
and this means that the comparison graph
while representing the entire
set of samples through the entire system
actually composed of k disjoint
subgraphs where each subgraph
represents samples and comparisons
being made by a specific player
and it might not be very surprising that
a
union of disjoint clicks is the right
graph to obtain
uh optimal result for this model but
come to think of it again it might be a
bit surprising it is the same graph that
gives optimal results for this model as
well as the streaming model
even though the constraints are very
different
so let's just sound the entire talk we
generalize the notion of collision based
testers or collision based testing using
the definition of comparison graph
where to graph edges basically dictate
which comparisons to make and we gave a
generic recipe for uniformity testing
in it works in various models
and the idea is basically to try
and translate all the constraints of the
model
and the constraint of the tester to
graph notations and try to
understand which is the correct
compression graph that fits
all the conditions that we
must hold and we saw how to apply this
to the streaming model and a little bit
taste how we should apply to the
simultaneous model
and hopefully this might help devising
uniformity testers in future models
wherever this problem might
arise is interesting
so thank you guys and stay safe